normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Conor
McGregor reacts to Dublin riots after
declaring Ireland is at War for this he
is under criminal investigation this is
how crazy it is take a look Conor
McGregor said he does not condone the
riots in Dublin but insisted that a
change must occur after a knife attack
left five people injured including three
children I like say I like how they say
five people just say three children and
two adults a 5-year-old girl was left in
critical condition after an attack in
Dublin on Thursday November 23rd which
led to Violent protests in the Irish
capital I will add some of the videos of
looting clearly not over immigration it
is a bunch of people just smashing and
stealing stuff and they're saying oh
they're far right no those guys that's
opportunistic we see those we see that
happen all the time but what we are
seeing is a lot of the Nationalist
Personalities in Europe pointing out
that the the indigenous populations of
these countries the white majority and
and and natives to these lands are are
are actually protesting they're actually
riding it's not just in Dublin we'll get
into more details in a in a minute on
France we'll talk about that another
segment but even in France you had I
believe it was an Algerian immigrant M
threatening uh uh they're here to stab
white people and then a teenager was
stabbed and killed so now you are
getting people pushing back let me let
me add to this I was hanging out with
friends this past holiday weekend and a
friend of mine uh introduced us to a
friend who was from Holland who is like
I would describe as left liberal
individual out of Europe who explained
that the right is winning because
they're all sick of immigration and she
went on to explain in her very thick
Dutch accent about there are too many
people that coming and they're they're
getting money from the government and
people are really fed up and I was like
wow now this is interesting cuz then
gear Wilder's party wins and this is
what we're saying it's fascinating this
is this is crazy eight eight years ago
you couldn't say men aren't women on
Twitter you would be banned now we're
see we are seeing nationalist
politicians winning more right sentiment
you're seeing Donald Trump winning among
18 to 34 year olds in more than one poll
NBC News is kind of pissed off about it
but we're seeing a lot of this now Conor
McGregor has another tweet let me see if
I can pull this one up he tweeted our
current government leader recently told
communities across Ireland he is
actually not asking them for permission
to plant multiple busloads of people in
the dead of night inside their Community
he is instead telling them we well now
it seems From Below said communities are
not going to ask him if they may stop if
they may stop them how do we feel I feel
transparency is the answer full
information should be attained and
divulged to gain support from the
communities of Ireland for this new
peculiar procedure that has begun over
the course of this year 2023 without it
fear Panic unrest can't can't we come to
our senses here take a look at this it
say in County lrim Irish men and women
have set a checkpoint to prevent Asylum
Seekers from being planted in their town
of course for this Irish police are
investigating Conor McGregor over his
tweets it's getting crazy I don't want
to jump too much into it because now
we've got more reports that they're
passing these Draconian hate speech laws
to ban this stuff I got to say man
Ireland occupied territory yeah Ireland
doesn't want your memes anymore
Ireland's trying prevent that's that's
seriously part of their new laws I mean
one of the issues here is that this uh
is such a tragic the Optics on this are
so tragic because not only was it young
children but it's young children being
walked to after school care after
departing an an all Irish School meaning
they only instruct in the Gaelic
language and so this is obviously to the
core of Irish culture something they
feel like they would want to protect
their language and their children I mean
even the stories coming out of it right
I think it was uh they were saying a
Brazilian bike messenger is the one who
like ultimately knocked this guy out
with his helmet and pinned him to the
ground well was interesting too because
it was the there were reports that it
was an Algerian immigrant and then
immediately yeah the BBC and all of
these other outlets were like it wasn't
an Algerian immigrant he was an
immigrant 20 years ago so he's
not that's different and it turns out
he's never had a job you know he's been
living on the door the whole time yes
and when you look at that it's
absolutely insane and those those hate
speech laws um one of the one of the
parts of that law it says a hate crime
is any criminal offense any criminal
offense which is perceived by the victim
or any other person to have been
motivated by Prejudice based on a
person's age disability race color
nationality ethnicity religion sexual
orientation or gender so it's any
criminal offense perceived as being
motivated which means the government
decides regardless it's messed up but do
you think this guy who perpetrated
attack would would be charged with a
hate crime no of course not well they're
saying that he was mentally deranged or
something because he was arrested for
illegal knife possession earlier this
year and let go Crim are up all over
because he was like mentally a problem
anyone who goes out and stabs children
is mentally deranged it's not an excuse
for the behavior nor is it is it an
answer uh uh uh to the complaints and
the questions of the of the indigenous
population who are concerned about an
IND idual who was actually slated to be
deported fought it and was able to stay
and then in 2008 and then went on to uh
uh stay in the country now I'm not sure
that in this I what I don't want to do
is take a single anecdote and say aha
immigration but the issue is there they
have not addressed it they have punished
the people who lived there and they have
helped Foster a very anti-immigration
sentiment where all it takes is one
story like this and that's the Tinder
that's the spark for the powder kick my
wife and I were in Ireland in 2018 and
uh we were out there for a week and like
we we spent like three or four days I
think in Dublin and we didn't see like I
didn't see any of this I everybody there
was Irish so I guess I guess this is
something that's come up in the last
five years or so I know England's got a
lot of issues there there's there's they
they kind of settle themselves into
their own little isolated Burrows and
stuff are they doing the same thing in
Ireland but this is this is the look I I
grew up in Chicago you walk around
Chicago you're not getting shot at right
however Chicago has more shootings than
I think at one point they call they
called it shyak because Chicago had more
shooting deaths than Iraq did but any
tourist who goes there is like I don't
see anything like this yeah the question
is are you in the neighborhoods are you
are and have you have you witnessed the
changes so when I went to Sweden several
years ago they they saw something like a
1,300% increase in murders now to
someone who doesn't know anything that
sounds terrifying like
1,300% yeah it's cuz they went from one
murder the year before to 13 murders and
so it the number is shocking if you're
from the United States you're imagining
Baltimore when someone's like the crimes
through the roof the murders are up a
th% you're like whoa you're imagining
crime in the United States which is it
can be bad if you're from the United
States and you go to Sweden you're like
wait your town of 350,000 had only 13
murders wow I mean that's bad but like
come to the United States yeah the
percentages seems cute but for the
people who live there that's a lot M
they don't have murder and not only that
they're having grenade attacks they had
they had I think they they have the
record for grenade attacks in a single
year in Sweden yeah and it's because
people who don't who aren't from there
are coming in and they're bringing I
believe it was from like um what war was
it there was it's been as long since I
cover this there were leftover weapons
used in war and the gangs got easy
access to them and started using them
against each other so there was like an
8-year-old British tourist I think was
was was killed in a grenade attack or
something like that around the time I I
had showed up had shown up so the point
is if you live if if your country is a
sleepy peaceful country with no murder
and they open their doors to immigration
murder skyrockets people are going to
protest and the the media manipulation
and the lies from government officials I
mean it's it's it it it only lasts so
long the the censorship the manipulation
social media censorship it's only so
long until people just snap and say no
way and I think especially with Ireland
the UK's
uh the way the UK treated their Asylum
Seekers ultimately Creeps in even if
they potentially didn't want it so 5
years ago maybe they fought it harder
but Northern Ireland which is obviously
in the same physical land as Ireland
even though it's part of the UK the
number one baby name in gallway was
Muhammad
in22 people were shocked by that people
were completely shocked but they were
like oh it's Liam nope no not Jack well
the average size of their family is
significantly bigger than anybody in
Europe I mean which is crazy when you
consider the Irish Catholics like they
had big big families now it's down to
like 1 point I think I think Europe like
averages like 1.5 children per family
and like I think anything less than 1.7
it's unsustainable ultimately
immigra is it two well if two people
only make one kid that's a good point
there you go I think the thing is
ultimately immigration issues are a
long-term negative investment right like
opening your doors to some immigration a
lot of countries start with like oh
we're we're a sleepy T we can offer
stuff we're wealthy and then ultimately
don't see the investment or they don't
see the implications of what they are
investing in long term which is that
bringing someone into your country
because you believe they're seeking
Asylum might be an honorable thing to do
but acclimating someone to your culture
and to everything that comes with being
a citizen is a long-term uh plan and I
don't think that mass immigration is a
sustainable way to do that ultimately I
think that's a big part of the problem
what you just hit on is you know in the
US we had a lot of immigration in the
20th century we've had that repeatedly
but the immigrants who came in the 20th
century in the early 20th century 1920s
whenever all of that Ellis Island type
of stuff they wanted to assimilate they
wanted to become American you know I've
talked about this before like my
grandparents my great-grandparents they
wanted to be American they wanted their
kids to be American they pushed English
on them you know my grandparents both
change my Italian grandparents changed
their names to be more American sounding
my grandmother went from Anna to an she
was like I'm just an now okay you know
but now we have this thing where we tell
everybody that American culture is trash
and they shouldn't want to be part of it
and they should bring their own culture
and maintain that and it's like once
we've given up our own culture and said
that it's garbage why would we expect
anyone else to want to be part of it
well Denver just um I was just reading
this report today that Denver is uh
trying to make it so they're encouraging
students like who have immigrated here
to continue to speak their own language
and not to learn English this is W
that's so dumb that's just so stupid I
got I was hanging out with the family
for the holidays and my girlfriend's
very based grandmother we we were
looking at photos of you know her her
parents Came From Italy and she's 90
this is crazy crazy it's it's amazing to
see these old photos and hear these
stories and she said that her parents
never taught her Italian and so she
comes their parents come here she's born
here and she said I wish they did teach
me Italian but they said we're we're in
America we will speak English and she
said they spoke broken English but they
tried their hardest to learn the
language and work in the communities and
make a good life and that's what they
did now they have a bunch of great kids
and a big big family and uh it's it's
crazy to see the expansion of the family
tree but I I feel like especially for uh
you know the the elements of my family
that were immigrants same thing come to
America learn the language fit in try
your best even when back then it's hard
for you know my family because of the
laws around misation mixed race families
are not allowed and stuff like that for
white Europeans it's a bit easier but
even still the attempt was we have to do
our best to fit in we have to be a part
of this it's a success and we're
investing in this experiment right we
want to be a part of growing this nation
and our our way of contributing to that
is to be a part of the culture and
actively have our children participate
and carry that forward and that's not
the way it works now and that's the the
the strange thing we'll get progressive
saying no we should let immigrant
enclaves live this way and and maintain
their culture because we're allowing
American culture to die out thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Mond
Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and
become a member over at timcast.net